Good morning John. There is a Roast Yourself challenge happening right now.
I've got some lyrics.
We're gonna do it. It's probably a bad idea.
(British voice-over says: "Absolutely brilliant")
Yo. Wassup, Hank Green. Here to roast myself like Ryan Higa said.
Givin' it all I got to give.
But she's not gonna.
Cause I'm a gangly white dude roasting myself on Youtube.
I'm maybe a little old to be doing this stuff... Maybe a little less silly in the future? Just chill it out a little bit.
I feel like... I feel like maybe focus on the educational stuff?
Not the fun, hip rapping challenges. That doesn't seem like a good idea.
Thanks for bearing with me on that one, entire world. Not just the people who watched, everyone. I apologize.
I don't know why I was like "Hey, let's do a song challenge! You don't have enough to do right now."
If you didn't know, Vidcon's coming up. I try not to talk too much about Vidcon because most people can't go. Even though it's a really good time.
But! For the first time ever this year, thanks to a sponsorship from Youtube, we are going to be able to Livestream significant portions of the event.
So yee, people who can't go, at least know that's a thing. If you wanna check it out, please do!
Thanks to Ryan Higa for injecting some silly into the Youtube community.
We take ourselves too seriously sometimes. No doubt about that.
Also, this is a thing we're doing now. It's a little tiny french llama vinyl toy. And I think it's cute.
We never done toys like this before. It's seven dollars and you can get it at DFTBA.com.
If there's a way for me to apologize for ever rapping, just let me know in the comments.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday. Tuesday! Not Wednesday. Never Wednesday. Tuesday! What the heck.